you want to know are you know which
functions are even and which ones are
odd and what does that exactly mean
right so you know the unit circle
already and I'll show you an example
here if you have a 30-degree angle
versus a negative 30-degree angle we
know the coordinates of these points on
the unit circle are root 3 over 2 1/2
root 3 over 2 negative 1/2 now on the
unit circle you know that the cosine is
the x-coordinate and the sine is the Y
and the tangent Y over X right so let's
just take for example this first one
here the sine of negative x what does
that mean that means if you take the
sine of a negative angle right it's
going to be the same value as the sine
of a positive angle but it's going to
have the opposite sign so if it's
negative it'll be positive it's positive
it'll be negative so for example if you
take the sine of 30 degrees sine of 30
degrees as 1/2 the sine of negative 30
degrees it's also 1/2 but see how it's
the opposite sign it's negative 1/2 so
that means that it's an odd function
okay so all these ones are odd now even
take a look at cosine for example cosine
of 30 degrees is the x-coordinate here
root 3 over 2 the cosine of negative 30
degrees it's still square root 3 over 2
so whether you're taking the cosine of a
negative angle or the same angle but
positive you're going to get the same
value so if this is a negative this
would be negative this is positive this
would be positive the only difference is
which direction you're going if you go
counterclockwise that's a positive angle
clockwise that's a negative angle and
you know that's the idea so basically
you can see if you can remember that
cosine and secant they're actually
reciprocals of one another so these are
both even meaning you're going to get
the same result back but all these other
ones sine cosecant tangent cotangent
you're gonna get the same value but it's
going to have the opposite sign so let's
look at an example now I'll show you how
this works so say you have cosine of
negative X well we know that's equal to
cosine of positive X right the positive
angle the sine of negative x is equal to
sine of X right but it has the opposite
all right value the opposite sine cosine
divided by sine is tangent cotangent I'm
sorry cotangent of X but a positive
divided by a negative equals a negative
so this whole thing will simplify down
to negative cotangent of X
so this has just been a brief overview
of understanding the even and odd
identities look at these even out of
trig functions so if you found this
beneficial subscribe to the channel
check out more math tutoring videos on
Mario's math tutoring YouTube channel
and I look forward to seeing in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon